big part of your life i'm just guessing
is people coming up to you and pitching
ideas for song parodies that's got to be
a big part of your life
um only when i go outside
yeah uh because my wife and i don't know
they've heard all the people i've heard
all the pictures and they know
yeah i mean every every bad idea you can
possibly think of
uh you know why don't you do a parody of
thriller
about phyllis stiller like that's very
timely yeah
that'd be good this audience doesn't
even know who phyllis diller is
and that's suggestion news from last
week so that's how behind the times they
are yeah but so
when you get are you polite to them in
that moment you just probably act like
oh yeah
yeah i'll get right to work on that yeah
yeah i don't do that i say that blows
that's why you're not beloved i know and
then i have two people with me that beat
the out of it
and i watch uh but you are as i said and
you just repeated you are beloved uh
and you must get i'm guessing throughout
your career you get a ton of fan mail i
know fan mail now is an old concept
right because everyone uses the internet
but
back in the 80s 90s you must get a ton
of fan mail yeah you know um
i i'm a recovering hoarder and uh i
never threw away
clearly you're getting rid of stuff
i saved every single fan letter i ever
got because you know their love letters
and how can you throw that away you know
but when i got married my wife realized
i had literally
dozens and dozens of beacon boxes full
of fan mail from the 80s in a storage
unit
and she was like you've got a full life
now you've got a family you're not going
to be seven year old 70 years old
reading
your old family like somebody used to
love me you know that's not going to
happen so
sadly i had to like kiss all the letters
goodbye and let them go
you did you actually get rid of them all
those fan likes i i i would have dropped
them for your house if i knew you wanted
them
sure i just write my name in over yours
dear conan and i would go they love me
uh you know andy and i were talking in
the commercial break uh because we're
allowed to
now and uh but annie we were talking
about and andy you said you went to
uh one of uh i've seen allen concert a
number
a number of times and you said the thing
that uh it was
that really took you by surprise was you
said the show was excellent but you're
that al's accordion playing is off the
chart it's fantastic
yes you really are an accomplished it's
not a gag you are an accomplished
accordion
i know how to play i'm sure there's like
13 year olds in ukraine that play
accordion better than me but
i do okay right i do okay let's not
mention ukraine yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah say lithuania yeah
yeah yeah i took lessons when i was
seven years old and uh
my parents uh decided there was a famous
accordion player named frankie yankovic
no relation but he was america's polka
king
uh and my parents decided there should
be at least one more accordion playing
yankovic in the world because your
your family reason that because you have
the same last name as a famous
accordion player their child must play
the accordion that's it yes
oh my god that's that's intense and so
you you took it very seriously you got
good
yeah yeah i got okay with it did it a
lot of people take up an instrument
because they think it's going to attract
uh a partner that's going to attract the
opposite sex
did you find that to be the case with
the accordion oh well when i was a kid
uh it didn't really apply to the ladies
uh
and then when i was a top 40 recording
artist still not so much
yeah uh it's not it's not the babe
magnet that you think it would be no no
i
i'm glad you said that because i didn't
think it would be a babe magazine
i just don't this there's something
about this and not a squeeze box
ah yeah i do this sometimes in the
subway and women just back away
it never works for me